there's no way your name's dr otto
octavious spider-man no way home blew
open the multiverse and our minds
between the crazy stunts breathtaking
cgi and chemistry between all the actors
on set the behind the scenes of no way
home is a sight to behold number one the
arrival of doc ock on the bridge is an
exciting and epic moment and the fight
between him and spider-man is equally
thrilling the filmmakers achieved this
awesome set piece by using a mix of
practical and visual effects
some of the cars being crushed and the
bridge being destroyed was done
practically on a giant blue screen set
and that explosion caused by green
goblin's pumpkin bomb all real digital
effects were used to enhance the scene
and create the rest of the environment
number two when spider-man stole the
return device from doctor strange we
knew there was about to be some awesome
action tom holland was hooked up to
wires to perform the stunts in the scene
which were then digitally removed in
editing holland practiced his car
jumping stun on a golf cart before
taking it in front of the cameras
cumberbatch was thoroughly impressed
with the work put in by the filmmakers
as were we the scale of what they have
is not to be underestimated number three
did you know that willem dafoe is
something of a stuntman himself defoe
was adamant that if he was going to
reprise his role as the iconic green
goblin he was to do as many of his own
stunts as possible i don't want to just
pop in there i want to do the action
because that's fun for me during the
spider-man green goblin fight scene in
the apartment building they actually
broke through multiple levels of
flooring the set was built specifically
for this stunt with blue screen lining
the halls for the cgi to fill in the
rest of the building
number four doc ox mechanical tentacles
were completely cgi in no way home a
huge difference from when alfred molina
first played the character in sam
raimi's spider-man 2. back then the arms
were physical props that were
puppeteered molina welcomed the new vfx
technology with open arms no pun
intended and he loved how they created
the appendages digitally you know it's
familiar but at the same time completely
new because the technology has moved on
molina was hooked up to a toothpick rig
to simulate the metal arms carrying him
around which made for some funny
behind-the-scenes moments we're chatting
and then all of a sudden he would just
kind of disappear
number five when doctor strange casts
the spell that kicks off the main
journey of the film he does so in a
dungy basement that he lights up with
the spell on set the basement was real
and they used circling lights to
simulate the light of the spell being
cast the round floating table that the
spell is cast on was held on a green
pole and also had circling lights on it
after some cgi magic the spell casting
scene was complete
number six tom and zendaya spent a lot
of time in this film falling from
heights one of their falls had them
jumping off of a very high up blue
platform while attached to a wire that
platform would later change into a metal
beam high up in the new york city air
with the help of cgi but that jump was
very real i mean i don't love heights
but i've learned to over you know the
last six years playing this character
number seven the incredible finale of no
way home took place at a modified statue
of liberty that held captain america
shield the very top of the statue was a
practical set as were parts of the base
everything else though was created with
a whole lot of cgi to complete this
climactic set piece
number eight that angry mob that is
present when peter and his friends are
going to school very real the rest of
the world not so much cgi was used to
create anything in the surrounding area
that wasn't the school you may be
wondering why they would go through all
that trouble the answer is this movie
was shot in atlanta georgia not new york
so any scenes with new york landscaping
in the background was 100
cgi we down here in georgia baby down
here in georgia number nine it's such a
simple scene that takes place in a
coffee shop how can there be cgi well
it's because of what we just explained
since filming was done in georgia cgi
had to be used to properly replicate new
york city so the inside of the coffee
shop is real but outside the windows
were giant blue screens where the new
york city street would be added in
post-production it would have been so
nice for them to go to college number 10
i don't think it will surprise anyone to
learn that the mirror dimension is
completely created with cgi however some
parts of the trippy sequence were filmed
on practical sets spider-man doing a
flip onto a warping building was tom
holland actually performing that move on
a beam and the subway trains that were
flying through the grand canyon were
shot using a small trained set piece
with tom holland and benedict
cumberbatch performing on top of it now
if only we could figure out how
spider-man did all that math so quickly
we have nothing but admiration for every
single person that brought spider-man no
way home to life the amount of detailed
cgi throughout the film is an impressive
feat and earned the film an oscar
nomination for best visual effects which
scene do you think had the best cgi
comment down below and let us know